so we're doing something we said we
wouldn't do again we're watching two
movies back to back no bourbon this time
you can see we are bourbon list but part
of that is because yeah part of it is
that one of these we can kind of stomach
that's the one we're about to watch the
Brendan Fraser mummy yes that's when
this came out everyone was going nuts
guess he came out the same time as
Phantom Menace sir everyone's like this
is the better movie well yeah but the
others Phantom Menace showers is a poor
man Sam Raimi yeah that's kind of what I
just remember I haven't seen the movie
in years I remember when I saw it I was
like I'm sorry but it just felt like Sam
Raimi's hand-me-downs it was like EI
mance rayder's a poor man's like yeah
like a bigger you were dead but a faker
CGI evil Dead's you can't appreciate it
as much but just like you get yeah yeah
I was just like I remember coming I was
like wasted time it's a big epic cartoon
the students yeah baby all the other
suck but I don't think that guys made a
good movie cent are you denying the
Majesty that is Rudyard Kipling's Jungle
Book
hey the only wanted to have the author's
title on top because it is so authentic
to the original book that had Samuel and
Carrie always in there educating for me
and it's not me I haven't seen this
since it came out of you I think Liz I
haven't really seen it since I'm on TV
basically yeah I watch it for like 20
minutes and then I am excited for some
late 90s early 2000s CG cuz I know it's
gonna look amazing so here we go this is
Brendan Fraser's The Mummy two names you
always wanted to see back to back
[Music]
it really is kind of sad that a ps3
could do this better nowadays hey it's
the other dark man I saw the gold
adulterer guys I know if that means when
the gold adulterer guys are out you know
it's fake as hell but it's still pretty
very nice is that one Winnie the Pooh
look at Egyptian cat God got your tongue
to cut to gene Wilder from ways and
saddles why are they strict press Start
never knowing what evil lay beneath it
Timothy's just telling this to like some
guy randomly in a bar you know I just
want to enjoy my Manhattan you all know
the history of the Manhattan years ago
an ancient curse must be sure he's a
poor man's and Kazarian then again when
it comes to films Hank Azaria isn't for
me to take this area statue Pazuzu right
behind him his career is going nowhere
leave him I kind of got a lame this was
you I survived raw and came through the
Stargate for this I have this everybody
I have this digital shine emphasizes
that I have this hey Frank did you see
that we all sort think it's cool we all
have one oh sorry I happy to see you
again
did you see I have this thing this sharp
pointy thing it's kind of bending on
your cheek but simplify it I have a
thing Oh see that's what you needed the
thing you left I may be on fire
this both simultaneously is in the great
movie but I'm impressed that there's any
practical effects I just think you know
much that shit would be CGI man that
said what the lobby is actually has more
practical effects than today's movie yes
yeah notice dump the mass luggage how we
doing question asked every day of
shooting every morning how we do it I'll
give it credit it knows how to let a
scene sir play big and let the music
take over for a bit and get some nice
sweet because that that's the scary
thing about it is this is this guy's
best yeah she's sort of Lee Precure in
Knightley Keira Knightley the Nira
Knightley okay this is where they bury
Boris Karloff seems to be ruling you
mean bucks
I hate bucks well he's dead my father
was a famous explorer you know weird
question how come a character in a movie
it's like well my parents had their well
my father did this it's like why can't
they just be why you dress in this well
I find this interesting that fasten
notes have been my father my parents
just I can own it and watch what passes
for backstory this is the aliens and the
Predators have fought here for years you
won't know it's so great this guy
doesn't smell at all I mean we'd be like
very nice
I just love sitting covered in locust
caring feeling these are be like me now
that should be immediately followed by
that's wow this is like the test real
right guys told you to leave of die
did we fucking stutter why do you even
offer rewards you're a fucking skeleton
bond so you just say work with me or I
fucking kill you
Pat Hingle I didn't know you was in this
with every new innovation Iloka labor
when they did the making of this can you
believe it like we shoot bullets there
and is like yeah I can cuz it looks
really fake and you think this justifies
the killing of innocent people to stop
this creature let me think
yes for 19:23 everybody is fucking
perfect teeth yeah this door doesn't
open she doesn't come out and no one
goes in right is he allowed to leave the
room with us
wow that's like Mortal Kombat
annihilation effects yeah boy she was
really dedicated together Shh they're
chanting the much better movie then the
stripped off evil dead evil dead
[Laughter]
[Music]
good for you wait what's my name I don't
know shit I'm dead
no one should have that happen to
Bernards lookout late 90s late that was
Milo's Facebook's like oh how much
screen time did that guy have it was
like yeah just before dude yeah I gotta
say for traveling via sandstorm they all
look amazing yeah I really thought they
were just gonna have like dirt coming up
their ass no her hair is still perm
fluffy he still a suspect polysemy
bagpipes realize this whole thing kind
of reminds me of the ducktales me except
this one looks more cartoony yes Oh God
actual real things look at these mummies
are actually here Fifty Shades of
fictitious array Jill Weiss I'll give it
this sometimes they are there if it's
actually kind of weird when they choose
not to be there it's like when they're
just marching in it's like you can't
just have them be there my credibility
this movie is taking my credibility I
was promised a career okay in that time
it took to spin I could grab like five
things
yep Falls too busy people me take they
said it was going to be come up as but
it's more like come down ins
I'm ramming it down I'm not guaranteeing
its gonna do it
what's happenin oink and together
usually you come back yours later like
wow that really blank then I remember it
I'm like that's almost exactly the same
yeah it's stupid it's easy but it's it's
a little fun it's the best thing Steven
summers did that's for damn yeah what a
sad state of affairs movies are in when
you say there's more black to go offense
cuz mommy you have more practical
effects than most movies nowadays okay
though it's like some of that CGI ice oh
no let's be honest and say it most of
it's pretty bad it wasn't even holding
up that well when it was released I
remember thinking it looked fake it was
beautiful yeah now it just is painfully
bare like the sandstorm was creative
Samson honestly the sandstorm from what
it is like just holds up enough I'm what
yeah and that's interesting but when
whenever he's just the skeleton mummy
like a looks like shit
so that is the mummy now we get to watch
the mummy I'm just gonna take a wild
guess and say it's gonna be worse than
this but we don't know maybe you'll be
good maybe we'll be like the two who
loved the time it didn't let at least
this one knew it was supposed to be kind
of stupid yeah the new one the trailers
just make may they look like like no
yeah serious man epic yeah Tom Cruise in
it
Kittridge you've never seen me very
upset yeah so I get a feel we're gonna
be very upset so we'll see you have that
one bye pray for us
you